[Música]
y ahora vamos al análisis el presidente
de Francia de Manuel macrón ofreció hace
minutos una entrevista en televisión
nacional para intentar calmar el
ambiente de los enfrentamientos tanto en
la calle como en el parlamento por la
reforma de las pensiones ofreció varias
declaraciones ante dos periodistas
después de sobrevivir a dos emociones de
censura por forzar la aprobación de la
Reforma de las pensiones y además
repitió que descarta que haya elecciones
anticipadas o cambios en su gabinete
sobre sus palabras y sobre el futuro de
las pensiones y de otras reformas vamos
a conversar con pascala de brujod él es
analista político y especialista en
relaciones internacionales pascala
Gracias por estar en directo a América
gran gusto muchas muchas Buenos días
patrona asegura que no retira la ley de
las pensiones pero al parecer la
enmienda Sí podría ser estudiada en el
tribunal constitucional hay opciones de
que se caiga la reforma o ya no hay nada
que negociar
Bueno muy bien lo dijiste el texto que
ya está considerado como adoptado está
ahora está a manos del Consejo
constitucional y el ira Pues sí está
totalmente constitucional o si debe ser
revisado pero definitivamente la
entrevista hoy del presidente Emmanuel
es su momento clave porque Emmanuel
macón ya desde tiempo intentó presentar
re explicar con la amplitud estratégica
En qué está ubicado
A qué Por qué hubo esa reforma Hacia
dónde vamos es decir pues que intentó re
explicar el panorama global desde su
reelección del año pasado Hacia dónde
vamos
entre tanto se ha tildado el presidente
de macron Pascal de antidemocrático por
forzar la aprobación de la Reforma a
través del artículo 49:3 sin embargo el
mandatario ha usado este mecanismo que
está en la Constitución porque entonces
la desconfianza de los franceses Más
allá de la rabia que produce que aumente
la edad de jubilación
No creo que hay que reponer un poco
orden en todo eso uno no hubo nada de
anticonstitucional en el proceso del
debate parlamentario que haya moción de
censura es el juego parlamentario no es
la primera hubo muchas desde 1958 y esas
nuevas instituciones una desde entonces
solamente funcionó fue en
1962 cuando cayó el gobierno de Joshua
pompidou dando al general de Gol en esa
época la iniciativa de reponer una nueva
mayoría hoy en día el
49.3 ese famoso artículo que hace parte
de una panoplia institucional que
permite Por cierto al poder ejecutivo a
ser prevalecer cuando hay un bloque su
posición hace parte de esos instrumentos
legales constitucionales y quiero
recordar que el último uso de este
artículo fue el número cien desde
1958 no es nada de nuevo ahora por
cierto toca sobre un texto muy sensible
que lleva sobre la relación al trabajo
sobre la relación al tiempo libre sobre
la relación a la vida y es la razón por
la cual el presidente de lo que dijo en
su entrevista lo inscribe hace bien la
separación entre acciones de política
diaria y el interés general y en eso
Tiene razones recordar que él ya no
puede ser candidato nuevamente ya en
2027 se acabará su mandato y no podrá
por Constitución lanzarse a un nuevo
período entonces ahí intentó mostrar una
dinámica en el interés general de
en un contexto complicado Como dijo la
guerra postcovid la inflación pero dando
ya un rumbo nuevo que por cierto no
habíamos oído Esas últimas semanas bueno
mire la gran pregunta En todo caso es si
va a cumplir esta entrevista que acaba
de entregar Emanuel macron el objetivo
de calmar la violencia las protestas y
sobre todo los grandes desacuerdos que
quedaron ahora en el parlamento sobre
todo después de hacer declaraciones que
podrían ser polémicas como por ejemplo
decir que no son valientes los que no
están a favor de la Reforma porque
dejarían era la carga a sus hijos más
adelante si no se soluciona el problema
ya o acusar a los sindicatos de no haber
buscado una alternativa o un punto medio
sino rechazar la reforma de plano
entonces realmente logrará conciliar a
través de las palabras que acaba de
decir
pues eso fue el objetivo vamos a ver
acaba de hablar mañana es el noveno día
de movilización nacional a raíz de
manifestaciones vamos a ver ahora por
cierto lo que llegó fue para inscribirse
en un nuevo diálogo nacional afirmó que
respetaba los sindicatos hemos visto
desde varios días que están ellos mismos
desbordados por movimientos que ahí
ponen disturbios todavía hubo Luna
pasado con muchos incendios puntuales en
París con una voluntad de desbordar pues
ese movimiento Cívico enmarcado por los
sindicatos propuso
retomando la palabra construir un nuevo
agenda parlamentario tiene todavía
cuatro años de mandato en llevar a cabo
y volver sobre el terreno al contacto
obviamente
cuando le preguntaron los periodistas A
diferencia de 2017 18 en el principio de
su primer mandato Por qué pues
adoptó esa reforma recordó y en pocos
años
existen primero muchos desafíos
importantes que ponen presión el desafío
internacional tenemos una guerra a las
puertas de la Unión Europea lo recuerdo
con consecuencias económicas la
inflación
tuvimos el covid con una presencia
Estatal muy importante el estado a
cualquier sea el precio que fue la
fórmula fue presente durante todo ese
periodo apoyando a los alargados y a la
empresa para que no pierdan el poder de
vivir el dinero es decir pues que sí
inscribió con un rumbo ahora vamos a ver
en las próximas horas y mañana si esas
palabras y ese rumbo enmarcado por el
interés general usando esa palabra el
presidente está entendida y vamos a
saberlo muy rápidamente Claro pero lo
que pasa es que ese interés general que
describe macron no es lo que se
significa en este momento en las calles
y usted lo decía mañana hay convocado
otra gran huelga los manifestantes han
dicho y los sindicatos principalmente
han dicho que no van a detener las
manifestaciones
en sin embargo lo que vemos es un macron
que no cambia su postura no muy firme en
su decisión desde la reforma de las
pensiones y de no dar marcha atrás Cuál
es Entonces ahora el objetivo que se
deben plantear o que se piensa usted que
se van a plantear los manifestantes en
las calles ante un presidente que no da
el brazo a torcer
Bueno me imagino que la jugada ahora es
ver cuál será la posición del Consejo
constitucional sobre este texto Pero
cómo recuerdo
hay dos cosas en cuanto a las
manifestaciones y convocatorias como muy
bien dijiste Mañana la la unión
intersindical Llama a grandes
manifestaciones
como vivimos ocho veces antes eso es
hace parte de ese debate social
en Francia pero por cierto existe una
violencia una violencia en término
político vimos la la fuerza de de esas
palabras
violentas en el en el parlamento primero
que se traduce a la calle en la calle
son pequeños movimientos yo vi Luna esa
noche yo estaba en París para ver para
oler un poco y eso en toda palabras
la situación y ahí sí vi Pues que eran
minorías Pero minorías organizadas
sabiendo pues poner ese ese desorden que
podía tener procurrir Imagínese de Caos
cuando Por cierto no es un caos pero eso
es un proyecto político y eso es lo que
vemos y entendemos hoy en día existe
también como proyecto político el
devolver de crisis política a una crisis
de régimen la situación entonces cuidado
con eso es la razón por la cual es
cierto Emanuel pues quiso redefinir el
rumbo redefinir el Horizonte
recordando Pues a través de lo que llegó
a través de sus palabras que no hay
ningún crisis de régimen en Francia las
instituciones funcionan pero Por cierto
agradecemos hemos traducido un debate
fuerte con una crisis política y ahora
pues él llama a ese concepto del interés
general Por cierto para calmar vamos a
ver como dije ya rápidamente esta semana
si ese mensaje está entendido y muy bien
dijiste es cierto que está firme su
posición pero a la vez extendió la mano
cuando afirmó esa voluntad de construir
una agenda parlamentaria porque las
reformas en Francia en el contexto
económico que conocemos a nivel nacional
que conocemos en Europa bajo la presión
de la guerra es cierto pues que eso
impone seguir con reforma bueno y va a
venir también una reforma de migración
lo mencionó el presidente en su
entrevista Así que tendremos que ver
cómo están los ánimos parlamentarios
cuando se aproximen esas semanas gracias
a ustedes analista político y
especialista en relaciones
internacionales por sus apreciaciones
Muy bien y a nuestros televidentes de
directo a América los invitamos a que
sigan con nosotros pausa pequeña y ya
volvemos con más
[Música]